in the uk but at what cost a person is
stretched to an ambulance on the south
coast today after arriving in a small
boat from france it's this the
government wants to deter by resettling
some new arrivals in rwanda but the plan
is controversial with concerns even
among home office staff who are working
on the policy
they'll be concerned about the kind of
inhumanity of it they'll be concerned
about whether it's legal and also
whether it's practical and so certainly
they're telling us that this is a
concern for them this many have said
this is not the sort of policy that they
wanted to see working in a department
that deals with immigration
now pretty patel has had to step in
despite an objection from her top civil
servant over value for money and push
through the plan using a ministerial
direction government sources say the
main concern is a lack of definitive
data on what benefits the policy will
bring
in rwanda accommodation blocks are
already being prepared but legal
challenges here are likely the un
refugee agency says the plan is a breach
of international law and hasn't worked
when other countries have tried it
people moved on from rwanda within
within a week
so it doesn't deter smuggling it
promotes it people went to south sudan
sudan
to
libya
and those that survived back to europe
so it was more hazardous and and and
more
work for the people smugglers than the
channel will ever be
so why with concerns here at the home
office and further afield is the home
secretary pushing this policy through
pretty patel has been under huge
pressure to get on top of the channel
crossings every attempt so far has
failed and the fact that there is now
concern inside this building about the
rwanda plan shows not only how
controversial the policy is but also the
level of uncertainty about whether it
will work
but there's also a political context to
this boris johnson is three weeks from
what's likely to be a difficult set of
local elections and he's under pressure
on other issues i don't think that this
is necessarily going to sway loads of
loads of swing voters but i think it
might might help shore up the
conservative base at a time when it has
been
leaving the party a little bit due to
party gate and other scandals that have
engulfed the government and the prime
minister but beyond the politics this is
really about people these families were
brought onto shore in kent earlier 181
came yesterday in just six boats
individual lives buffeted by issues
outside their control both here and
abroad
rob powell sky news in westminster